cool now that we know we can use logging
to help us debug our app we're going to
return to this networking code snippet
here and drop it into the sunshine app
to query for actual weather data open up
your project to mainactivity.java in
this class scroll down to the
placeholder fragment class within the
placeholder fragment class in the
oncreateview method scroll down and go
ahead and add the networking code
snippet here the github link is pasted
below again if you need it
you may need to enable these options in
auto import or add the imports manually
see the instructions below when you run
the app you'll see that it crashes use
logcat to figure out which error is the
guilty culprit that caused the crash
we're assuming that for this quiz
question you're using a device that's
running a honeycomb or later use the
emulator if needed